maman a jamais m'a jamais donné
l'impression que j'étais différent donc
je n'avais pas l'impression que c'était
bizarre
[Musique]
moi quand j'avais trois quatre cinq ans
je portais des chiffons sur ma tête pour
avoir des longs cheveux parce que je
voulais être une princesse je me déguise
en princesse halloween
j'étais fan de lady gaga j'avais des
barbies plein sa grande barbe et donc
c'était et voilà donc en fait c'était
cette taça a toujours été là et maman a
jamais m'a jamais donné l'impression que
j'étais différent donc je n'avais pas
l'impression que c'était bizarre mais
l'impression que c'est un train de faire
quelque chose de deux voilà qui change
le monde avec ton chiffon sur ta tête
c'était juste en mode j'ai envie de
porter un jugement sur ma tête et
personne me donne l impression que que
j'étais en train de faire quelque chose
de d'étrange
[Musique]
c'était un peu compliqué parce que les
camarades de classe n'était pas tout
spécialement fan de moi et qui a vu
beaucoup de de critiques beaucoup
d'insultés tout et je pense que je
partageais pas spécialement ça avec
maman non un peu j'en parlais pas trop
trop bas on entend parler pas trop quand
il rentre et je voyais très bien à son à
sa façon de parler à sa façon d'échanger
avec son frère comment comment il était
donc je ne savais pas précisément si
c'était juste l'angoissent scolaire
parce qu'il n'a pas compris un cours ou
si c'était plus les enfants dans la cour
de récréation qui qu'il aurait dit
quelque chose de malveillant
donc voilà je ce que j'essayais de faire
juste c'est de lui faire comprendre
qu'il était maman dans le cocon familial
bien au chaud que rien ne pouvait lui
arriver dans cette petit appartement
enfin même l'impression que voilà tout
va bien ne t'inquiète pas ça ira mieux
et donc ça me rassure et déjà beau
j'étais perdue on est tous c'est très
normal c je dis ça parce qu'il faut pas
paniquer parce que j'ai paniqué moi j'ai
pas dis qu'est ce qu'être qui se passe
je suis tout parce que voilà on nous
posait des questions auxquelles je
pouvais pas répondre sur ma sexualité
alors que j'avais pas de vie sexuelle
non moi je te dis
prends ton temps soit perdue c'est bien
il faut il faut l'être et tapas et ça
passe et ça ira très bien
quoi qu'il arrive ça ira bien je trouve
ça dommage que juste ma particularité a
fait qu'on a on a fait de moi un sujet
de débat en fait juste parce que je suis
un mec qui porte une perruque on me
donne un rôle un petit peu que j'ai pas
demandé à avoir
moi je fais de la musique voilà